good morning Kurt how are you I'm good
dan how are you great we're curious
about the MVP vote do you have a vote I
do not have a vote no if you did who's
your MVP if I did my MVP Matt Ryan I
just think he's been great this year on
a team that doesn't have many ways to
win he's got to play well for them to
win a nice play exceptional all year
long Derek Carr's probably my second
place guy or Ezekiel Elliott I know he's
rusty running back and we don't give
running back as much love but I don't
believe Dallas's anywhere close to to
where they're at right now if if that
running game isn't going and obviously
Zeke leaving million rushing if you
needed to win and you can pick any
quarterback in the postseason who's your
quarterback Brady but he's not you're
not your MVP now did the power beams
does that hurt him it that does in my
mind just because knowing the
quarterback position and understanding
the MVP race one bad game one slip-up
can cost you in that race and so to take
out a fourth of the season although I
will say I believe tom has been the best
player win he's been on the field for
those 12 games he's been the best player
in the league but it's just so hard for
me because I just understand how this
thing works and you know flip ups at any
point in time can cost you that award so
I gotta lean towards a guy that plays at
an MVP type level but played all 16
games over 12 how do you explain what
Aaron Rodgers does yeah I mean it's hard
to explain you know he's a guy just so
special when he when he had lips and and
there's even times when I'm not even
sure he really looked at the concept of
a play I think he just looks to have
them because he knows he's unbelievable
and they're unbelievable when that
happens I think early in the year that
hurt him there was a lot of things
happening within the framework and
timing of the offense that he was
missing early on and now he's kind of
got back to making more of those plays
plus doing the extra and when that
happens with Aaron Rodgers you see what
we've seen is that it's incredible it's
special and your team wins when that
happens whose skills would you one of
all these quarterbacks I mean just
physically I mean I don't know if we've
seen a quarterback like Aaron Rodgers
with what he can do physically and I'm
talking possibly ever he is just so
gifted has such a great feel for that
buying time and and how to get open and
then he can throw from so many different
places and I know that you know it's
it's as a quarterback you understand
that that there's so much that goes into
balance and using your hips and being
accurate when your feeder in a lot of
different positions and if you watch
Aaron he's a guy would never you know
tell a young quarterback here's training
tape go watch Aaron Rodgers you would
never do that because he's all over the
place but he is so gifted with his arm
and he's got such great balance and with
his hips and weight transfer with his
hips that he makes throws I mean I
watched take just a couple weeks ago and
he's falling to his left and never
really sets his feet and throws the ball
75 yards I mean I I never threw said if
I your life more you know more or less
when you're falling to your left it's
just incredible what he can do with the
ball so I would love that physical
talent to go along with some of the
things that I did he's Kurt Warner from
the NFL Network you can see Kurt NFL
gameday morning they'll be on the air
saturday at noon eastern sunday and 9
a.m. eastern why haven't we bought into
Kansas City or Atlanta well I think with
Kansas City yeah we're always going to
point to the quarterback and as great as
alex has been at winning games and we
know bottom line is win games and he's
done it as well as anybody over the last
few years but
the bottom line I believe if the
quarterback is you want to see a guy
that's willing to carry a team with his
right arm you believe that when it comes
time is at some point whether playing
Brady or whatever you have to win a game
with your right arm and I think we're
all and I'm one of those guys I believe
Alex can do it I don't there's any
question he can make all the throws and
the big throws I'm just I question
whether he's willing to do it whether
he's willing to take those chances and
be the reason that they lose and also
the reason that they win and I think
that's what holds us back is I don't
know if he'll do that I think you know
he'll protect the ball and he won't make
the mistakes but will he be able to make
some special plays in in that special
game to get them to the next level and I
think that's why we hesitate there with
Atlanta I think we hesitate because it
almost has to be a perfect world to
believe that they're going to win
numerous games in the playoffs by that I
mean playing inside because matt ryan
hasn't been characteristically in the
past as good outside in whether their
defense you feel like there's a lot of
teams that could put up 40 points
against their defense and so you're
going to have to outscore them which
again falls to the quarterback being
great every time out and that to me is I
think the worry with his team is they're
really good and that's playing really
well and they've got a lot of weapons
but you just feel like they're going to
have that score everybody and can they
do that depending on you know who ends
up playing against them and where they
have to go are they capable of doing
that you know every time out i mean the
fortunate thing is they're only going to
have to get to get to the Super Bowl but
it's just hard a lot of times you got to
win different ways in the playoffs and
I'm not sure you look at Atlantic ok
they could win different kinds of games
the last playoff defense you'd want to
face assume last playoff defense it's a
good question um-hmm I think all of them
have some issues I think Houston's
defense is playing really well right now
but you don't worry about them as much
as you don't think they're going to
score any points on offense yeah
balichek always got to throw something
different at you so that to me is
worrisome and they stop you from scoring
so it's hard to just take one and take
it away from the scenario I like Kansas
City's the way they turn the ball over
so you always feel as a quarterback if
you give me a couple turnovers I'll win
but I'm probably just going to say New
England just because I look at the whole
situation just know the scheme is going
to be different every time out so you
have to prepare differently it's not
like some teams where you say okay I
know what they're going to do I can
figure out a way in a week to attack
what they do as long as we don't make
mistakes but Belichick is gonna throw
different things at you which to me
makes it makes it the most difficult
could you start for Oakland or houston
this weekend could I yep uh i don't i
don't know i mean on paper i could if
they had a high and if i gave you two
weeks to prepare thank ya i have no idea
physically I feel great uh you know on a
board I know what I'm doing but it
really comes down to the speed of the
game and can you slow things down where
you can react like you want to react
Houston a better chance I think there
was probably some things that I could do
to give them a better chance at the
quarterback position i don't know if
it's it's everything right now because i
haven't done it in a long time i'm
trying to get you out of retirement but
you know you're all the same I you know
I'm just trying to add one more element
where somebody goes he's a lock for the
Hall of Fame now look what he do you oh
you told me I'll never forget you tell
me years ago if I got Arizona to the
Super Bowl I was a lot Hall of Fame so
what else do I need to do i'm just
banking on what you told me dan and i'm
just gonna sit back and rest on the
laurels will see the problem is i should
have said win the superbowl you just
start getting to this area at that point
I'm that was a mirror and what's gone
that would have been a miracle why don't
you come back and play for the browns Oh
no thanks no thanks but isn't it amazing
that we got a playoff game our first
playoff game is going to possibly be
Connor cook and then Brock Osweiler who
was benched a couple of hundred by their
team crazy unbelievable that that's
that's a playoff matchup crazy hey great
to talk to you tell rich and boys we
settle oh and we'll talk to you during
the playoffs thank you sounds great oh
yeah that's a Kurt Warner I always ask
him that question I'll keep asking until
he finally says no I wouldn't be better
than Brock Osweiler I wouldn't give them
a better chance if you gave him a month
he would be a better option the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]